libertarians forget that the winds are
generally socially economically in their
favor it is not in their interest to
just obstruct on the grounds that
everything gets worse if Congress does
nothing what really happens if Congress
does nothing is power flows to the
president who does whatever he damn well
pleases hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Jonathan Roush of the Brookings
Institution his latest book is political
realism how hacks machines big money and
backroom deals can strengthen American
democracy John thanks for talking to us
Nick it's always great to see you and
I'm glad to see you've changed to black
today that's right this is the
Frankenstein ensemble the new yes you
know this book is fascinating it's
available for free at the Brookings
Institute that's very short on yes it's
sixteen thousand words so you can read
it on your plane and it is a
particularly challenging document I
think to libertarians because what
you're saying is that there are problems
with our political system and that
libertarians progressives and populist
are part of the problem here because as
a general rule we expect a kind of
dogmatic allegiance to extreme
ideological positions in the political
realm and that that crashes the system
in a way that hurts everything talk a
little bit about political realism what
do you mean by that term and then let's
talk about why machine politics weren't
as bad as you know they usually are
perceived to be so the forward bumper
sticker version of political realism is
let politicians be politicians the very
slightly longer explanation is in order
to organize politics and for anything to
work you need political machines or
things that function like political
machines these are informal hierarchies
that make politicians accountable to
each other because in our system
politicians cannot reward and punish
each other directly it's not like
Britain where you can basically be fired
if you vote against the party so you
have to create these networks where they
incentivize each other so that followers
will follow leaders and that requires
stuff like pork barrel spending and
political
machines it requires some control of the
ballots so you can protect your people
and they can take a tough vote the
problem is that if you're an idealist
those kinds of machines and structures
don't look really good when you hold
them up to the light and say is this
perfect is it beautiful so we spent the
last four years demolishing all of that
equipment and libertarians have been a
big part of that in the book you know or
the 2016 presidential race is a kind of
example of the breakdown of the system
that you're talking about you wouldn't
have a Donald Trump or a ben Carson or
arguably a Bernie Sanders running if
political machines and if political
hierarchy of party hierarchies we're
still functioning in a in a meaningful
way well that's right and the Republican
Party has been it's an extraordinary
watch completely helpless to do anything
about what amounts to an insurgency
against the Republican brand by complete
outsiders with a lot of money by the way
not just Trump one of the results are
trying to get the politics out of
politics and clean it up with all these
rules and stuff is that you now so
restricted how much money the parties
can raise and spend and how they spend
it that you've got money flowing most of
these outside political machines which
are not accountable to anybody they're
not accountable to voters per se but
they're accountable to the people who
are funding them and that's the problem
right that in primaries say you if you
have a pack super PAC that is funneling
a lot of money and challenging people in
primaries they can get an extreme person
on the on the ballot who may not even
represent the party whose name they're
appearing that so often does not
represent the party oh yeah we don't
know who they're accountable to because
we often don't even know who they
actually are but the other problem that
people don't think about is while we're
all focusing on where's the money going
in the campaign it's what happens after
they campaign the other 364 days of the
year you gotta govern what happens when
John Boehner tries to get the votes
together to keep the government open for
example or pass an immigration bill
which he would have liked to have done
and he can't get anyone to do it because
all his guys are more afraid of
the shadow packs the the super PACs and
the outside money than they are of him
well let's talk about that because you
know part of it the problem why we need
or why you argue why we need the
political parties why we need machines
why we need hacks in a certain level is
to get stuff done to get [ __ ] done right
so what happened when the government
suspended operations for a few days I
mean did anything you know what what is
not getting done that needs to get done
sometimes things don't get done because
there's no consensus and people don't
know what to do fixing Medicare that's
really hard no one knows what to do the
problem is when you have a consensus
when you have a plan when both parties
want to get the thing done and despite
the fact that a majority of members of
both parties in Congress and the
president want to get it done it still
doesn't get done so you know going back
to 2000 we've had the Bush tax breaks
Medicare Part D we've had the Patriot
Act two authorizations of use of
military force sarbanes-oxley the bush
stimulus in 2008 tarp the Obama stimulus
multiple debt limit increases the
expansion of tarp under Obama the Obama
stimulus Obamacare dot frank I mean it
seems to me we're not we're getting a
lot of big stuff done the most of which
I find a contemptible but you know
that's getting done and then the
day-to-day stuff what is it something
like sixty percent of the federal of
federal spending and federal activities
effectively on autopilot because its
debt and you know entitlement so is
there you know what what is the problem
then that John Boehner can't whip his
his people into shape well first of all
some of the stuff you mention is really
old yeah and this phenomenon is it's now
unfolding is actually pretty new so they
huge yeah the huge entry of the super
PAC monies come in the last four or five
years and it's only as recently as 2012
that the super PACs began to out span
the mainstream political party and
that's when you really get the situation
where John Boehner doesn't really have
the tools you need it's also very
recently that you get rid of earmarks
which were one of the last available
tools for incentivizing people to take
hard votes if you want to fix Medicare
or social security you're going to
give that Florida congressman something
maybe he needs a post office so that's
one issue another is if you're the type
of liberal that counts votes and looks
at congressional productivity I know you
don't but that looks Tara recently it's
been off a cliff but what I worry about
is every decade once or twice in a
decade you get a chance to do a real
reform it should have been immigration
reform that Senate bill wasn't perfect
but it was pretty good in there was a
majority of people in both chambers and
both parties and a president that wanted
to get that done it died because a
minority of the Republican caucus would
not be controlled by their own
leadership and the leadership had no
aces you that that's a big missed
opportunity you also couldn't fund the
Homeland Security Department room
despite the fact that everyone wanted to
do that so no buts let's set aside the
policy all right when the political
system is not just failing to decide
because it doesn't know what to do or it
disagrees but can't decide even when it
knows what it wants to do that's a
different kind of problem you know the
government has not really passed a true
budget in years and the Senate under
Democratic control actually went for
years without even without even
producing a document that they didn't
vote on they didn't even produce the
document is that a systemic failure is
that a failure of leadership I think
it's looking in the wrong place name one
of the things that a lot of libertarians
and progressives share is looking with
utter contempt and disdain on
appropriations committees liberals think
you know they're closed they're going on
their smoke-filled rooms and
libertarians think these are these are
log rollers this is pork at its worst in
fact what appropriations committees did
was fairly quiet meetings of grown-ups
to apportion the budget not perfectly
but they were actually a force for
restraint and when we blew them away and
substituted entitlements or chaos which
is what we got now we lost a lot of the
control that we use to have a rather
money when so that's I mean that's a
challenge to people who think
smoke-filled rooms are always the wrong
answer you know and I'm going to
mispronounces name moises name
a couple years ago wrote a book called
the end of power where he charted
internationally many large organizations
and he's talking about large
corporations as well as central
government's churches and religions has
booked the end of power charted how it's
harder and harder to actually
centralized power and get things done on
a certain level a you know because of a
variety of technological changes in
social changes the power is leeching out
in the system is what you're talking
about data basically it's just it's not
that you're wrong in in even saying this
stuff should be done differently but
that that age is past that age is
definitely past you can't turn back the
clock you can't go back to Tammany Hall
even if you wanted to I don't want to
but that arguments a bit of a straw man
because it forgets that although times
have changed and we've got social media
and lots of things are different a lot
of this not all of it but a significant
part as a result of deliberate policy
choices we deliberately chose to get rid
of earmarks we deliberately chose to
blow up the old seniority system and
committee structures in Congress there
was some bad in those system but there
was also a lot of good we deliberately
chose campaign finance laws that sharply
limited the amount of money that parties
could raise and limited even more
weirdly their ability to spend it on
their own candidate talk a little bit
about what you mean you're not saying
we're not going to get money out of
politics and money and politics it's not
necessarily a bad thing but one of the
choices are one of the policies you say
that I think is pretty interesting is to
say let people give as much money as
they want you know that they can give to
super PACs directly to candidates or
parties how does that change the
equation basically what we've been
trying to do for 40 years now is
sequester politicians for money the
problem is you create a black market for
money an idea that any libertarian will
be familiar with and you simply drive
the money outside accountable channels
into these shadow networks it's now
clear that even if the Supreme Court
would let you ban outside money there's
no practical way to do it the best
answer flawed but better than any other
is to bring that money back inside the
system funnel it through the parties
which are very large organizations you
can't buy a whole political party maybe
you could buy a chunk of a congressman
but you can't buy a whole party they're
more accountable than anyone else they
can move that money around and begin to
use it as an incentive they can tell a
member look if you vote for this
Medicare cut we're going to help you in
your race and we have the money to do it
so there are a lot of people actually
who are increasingly saying let's bring
the money back in instead of trying to
drive it out let's it's kind of like
marijuana legalization you know it's
just not working in the underground
economy give an example of where giving
somebody a little earmark allowed for a
much greater good to take place used to
happen all the time and people like
trent lott former senate majority leader
are on record as having said that one of
john boehner is big problems is that he
doesn't have any incentives anymore
there's really nothing that he can give
his members to give him for a vote and
that makes life just a whole lot more
difficult when you're trying to do
transactions i mean i can't we don't
know yeah but you know was that was just
it wasn't the whole ball game in some
ways it was only a small piece of it but
it was something you could do to bring
that reluctant personal long and when
you lost it both because of procedural
changes and because the tea party said
we're going to vote against people who
take your marks it was kind of in some
ways the straw that broke the camels but
I said you know and I'm thinking back to
I guess it was ben nelson in Nebraska
who was among the land he basically won
the Tontine he was the last holdout of
Obamacare say he got a bunch of stuff
directed to the braska and to his
constituents for that I mean is that
that era has kind of ended that well I
think if earmarks were allowed that
would be a good thing I think it would
help somewhat at the margins people
forget that by the time earmarks were
abolished they had already been reformed
run they were transparent they were all
posted online there was systems to get
them it was like applying for a grant it
wasn't the old back room anymore so I
bring him back I also wouldn't claim
that it would change the world but I'm
really trying to do with this book and
indeed this interview is get people to
think differently to begin to think
about the importance of transactional
politics and deal-making as the only way
to get anything other than chaos which
is what we increasingly have right now
and they're about all the tools that
politicians need to do that that's
earmarks that's money its control of the
ballot it's privacy that is quiet
mythical privacy oolitic 'old privacy
which we've made no art let me ask
because from a libertarian perspective
and if you're trying to convince
libertarians you know we've seen across
the government not so much in the
federal government but in past years
we've seen gay marriage reform we've
seen or legalization we've seen pot
medical marijuana and an increasingly
recreational pot go the right way
typically at the you know while being
antagonized by you know from the federal
government we've seen some reforms of
the Patriot Act and surveillance we've
seen a new discussion about foreign
policy starting to kind of filter
through you know what what do
libertarians get if they sign on to this
transactional idea that politics is not
about ideals or extremes it's about
incremental change in the right
direction so I mentioned earlier that if
we're lucky we get one big reform in a
decade if you think about the direction
of reform the last few decades in the
70s transportation deregulation
revolutionary market people love it in
the 80s tax reform very big deal in its
time really helped for a while market
people loved it simpler flatter cleaner
tax code in the 90s it was welfare
reform in the 90s it was also a new kind
of farm bill which was a step in the
right direction for unrelated reasons it
didn't work out in the 2000s it would
have been social security reform if we
hadn't entered this owner before and now
it would have been immigration reform
the next one needs to be entitlement
reform libertarians forget that the
winds are generally socially
economically in their favor it is not in
their interest to just obstruct on the
grounds that everything gets worse if
Congress does nothing what really
happens if Congress does nothing is
power flows to the president who does
whatever he download pleases you you
also key in on
a deal in Utah about gay marriage that
kind of points to the type of positive
outcomes you know that happen if people
are adult enough to take transactional
politics seriously talk a little bit
about what happened there and why that's
a model we should be looking at as a way
of going forward so Utah had a bunch of
gay people who wanted a gay rights bill
discrimination protections and it had a
bunch of Mormon people who are not on
board with as they call it the gay
lifestyle but who decided that they were
okay with anti-discrimination law if it
included religious protections and what
then happened is a process where some
people went behind closed doors for a
period of intense conversations began
quietly over a period of years then much
more focused and came out with a deal
now this would be if not illegal very
difficult in many political environments
today because it's it's what a lot of
progressives hate it's quiet secret
negotiation but it turns out if you want
to get a bunch of people to really put
their cards on the table and start
saying what do you need what do I need
how do we move forward on this that's
what you got to be able to do and people
forget transactional politics isn't just
log rolling its social conciliation it's
how we get along as a society how we
negotiate with each other as human
beings and politics and when you talk
about the religious exemptions for anted
anti-discrimination laws that would
essentially allow businesses or people
in Utah to be able to step out of a
situation like you know a cake you know
baking a cake for a gay marriage
reception or something yeah you Utah
specifically because of the nature of
their a lot did you get into what
businesses have to do with customers
they don't have a public accommodations
you can line in there law but what it
did mean is for example Brigham Young
University will not be required to
recognize gay couples for student
housing and there are lots of other
exemptions like that that make it make
it much easier for the Mormon Church to
go on about its business the new book
which I highly recommend everybody
reading it's a quick read of fast read
and a genuinely provocative and
intriguing one is political realism how
hacks machines big money and backroom
deals can strength
American democracy and one hundred
percent free that's right it's it's
worth every penny too so thank you
jonathan Roush for the Brookings
Institution for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie